we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p the eggman called in
about the buffalo terrorist shooting and
right-wing media the eggman says there's
not been a lot of coverage of it on
right-wing media uh maybe a lot of
right-wingers won't even know it
happened take a listen to this
hi dave so that mass shooting that
occurred in buffalo new york is kind of
close to my house you know not very
close but in the area so i watched on
the news regularly since it happened and
i'm and i'm sorry but i pay for fox news
and all the right-wing news channels
also because i have no internet by the
way there's really if you have cable
there's really no way not to pay for fox
fox isn't a channel where you can say i
don't want it so unfortunately any of us
who have a cable subscription
you have no choice but to pay for fox
news and that's that's a real shame
sorry i have to get cable so i flip back
on all the news channels and the only
one carrying it well the only ones are
the
so-called left-wing liberal channels
right cnn msnbc and i do have like
newsmax and
news now there's other right-wing news
channels dave you ever hear about news
now it's really and oh anyway
none of those channels were carrying the
shooting and i went i would go out and
come back at my house all weekend long i
just kept checking
none of the right-wing channels were
covering the mass shooting the racist
mass shooting in buffalo new york this
morning i turned the news to go to work
and i did see it on fox and friends a
little bit
do you think that the
uh left-wing media is showing it too
much or the right-wing media is
avoiding it because a white guy killed
black people it's obviously racist
what's going on dave shalom all right
yeah shalom to the egg man no this so so
a couple of different things one
in the first 48 hours after such an
incident um it is major news and it
makes sense that it would be covered i
don't think the media outlets covering
it are covering it too much there is one
other thing going on on the right a lot
of stations are very minimally covering
it or not covering it at all because of
the obviously right-leaning
great replacement theory racist white
nationalist neo-nazi motivations of the
shooter
but we've also seen as we looked at
earlier in the show
fox news doing the well you know violent
video games might be what's to blame
here
and fox news talking about oh terrorists
might come through the southern border
from other countries but what about the
domestic terrorists that's here and that
killed 10 people so the what the
right-wing media outlets that are
covering it are covering it in a
completely dishonest way i don't know
what's worse not covering it at all or
covering it in a way that completely
distorts people's understanding of it
but the eggman's conclusion is accurate
people who only get their news from
right-wing media
if they know about the mass shooting in
buffalo
are going to have a very skewed
perspective on what it is that took
place and we'll talk about this more on
today's bonus show this is terrible news
pennsylvania u.s senate candidate john
fetterman has suffered a stroke but says
that he's well on his way to a full
recovery this is the primaries tomorrow
okay so we're going to talk about that
mitch mcconnell says that the senate is
going to pass the largest ukraine aid
package ever on wednesday
and lastly elon musk says that the
twitter legal team came to him and said
sir you violated an nda a non-disclosure
agreement what's that all about and
what's happening with musk purchasing
twitter i still i didn't think it was
going to happen and i still don't think
it will
um all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show get access to the
bonus show today by signing up at
joinedpakman.com or
get access to the bonus show at a
discount on monday may 30th that's
memorial day memorial day there will be
no new show we'll be off for the holiday
but we will be doing a one-day
membership special if you've been
thinking ah maybe i'll get a membership
i don't know
the perfect day the best day to sign up
is monday memorial day just get on our
newsletter at davidpakman.com and in the
morning on memorial day you'll get an
email telling you how to sign up